i need some oxygen because what i'm
about to say
is explosive that's it let's check in
with stacy hello
well you know every episode of ours is
quite explosive but i want to say that
you know that old saying that no one
expects the spanish inquisition yeah
well
no one actually expects money printer go
no one actually expects the economist
at the central banks in the treasury
to actually listen to those academics
to listen to the ivy tower economist
telling them to print money uh well you
know the world's greatest economist
is the ivory tower on top of the ivory
tower the man who wrote the defining
textbook that all economists follow
around the world the number one the
premier
economic mind of our generation of our
century is of course plucky
hello i'm blocky
the world's greatest economist
right no one expects the treasury
to abide by the sayings of pluto
nobody excuse it yes martial
okay cool so um with that i want to
point out that here's a headline and
we're going to go into this about like
why
no one actually expected it when i say
no one people who make decisions
financial decisions and economic
decisions for the manufacturing entities
for the large corporations around the
world
and you see that with intel and tsmc on
chip
shortage after blowing 84 billion
dollars on share buybacks since 2011
and now woefully behind intel clamors
for 50 billion dollars in subsidies for
u.s
chip industry intel is getting 50
billion dollars they're one of a
few companies getting 50 billion dollars
in subsidies in the latest of the
trillions of dollars package
and they're getting a 50 billion dollars
to help build the foundry
you know build some more semiconductor
chips in america
and on the other hand tsmc was uh who is
the lar which is the largest
manufacturer of these uh
semiconductor chips which is shutting
down production all over the world
because of the shortages of it
what happened is they did not expect as
i i won't shriek as much but this is
plucky
and uh plucky is an economist who works
for the central bank
and uh offers his advice never have any
central banks ever actually taken his
advice because he's always so absurd and
he shrieks as you've heard him speak
and nobody's ever taken his advice but
these are uh
different times these are unique times
and they seem to be listening
to his ideas about mmt and money
printing and negative interest rates
so what happened is tsmc did not
expect central banks or treasuries to
listen to absurd
economic advice right so they thought
pandemic
global economy shuts down therefore
people aren't going to buy
goods and services like washing machines
like automobiles
they didn't expect trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars to be
thrown out the window
at the the population across america so
that's
not what they were expecting and they
themselves last year at this time
cut orders all these uh manufacturers
like automobile
uh washing machines all that sort of
stuff they shut they they pulled their
orders that they we
won't need semiconductor chips because
everything's shut down but little did
they know
if there's another flip side to that
story about there's money printing
and then there's price signals right so
the problem with having
money printing and also near zero
percent or zero percent interest rates
is that it destroys
price signals in the economy because
you're saying the underlying fundamental
substance of the economy that is money
money itself
is the raw material of economics of
capitalism
you're saying it has a zero value so
therefore if you have zero value for the
substance of your economy
it's very very difficult to build
something that you can point to and say
well that has value
and that one doesn't have any value
because they they're both equally value
less
because they're both based on something
that has no
price signal has no intrinsic no
inherent no economic
value and so in the case of intel they
were allowed to buy back all their stock
with zero percent
interest and as such they were not in
the business of capital expense or to
create more business opportunities or to
hire more workers
instead they just played the system
because they realized price signals are
broken and we're going to make money by
capitalizing on the large s of the
psychotics at the plucky bank the first
plucky bank
currently run by jay powell so they then
go into a chip shortage because the
signals weren't clear to them they
become toned down if you
involved in male investment and you lose
track of
what you do for a living you know and
andy grove who is running intel who
founded intel he's long gone the people
there now
can't hear the market they don't see the
market all they know is they're getting
free money now they're without chips
so they're scrambling oh where does the
money come from now to build
chips to meet supply meet demand
oh it's going to come from the
government government money printing
so it exacerbates the problem that's why
we have this bermuda triangle effect
all corporations are flying over the
bermuda triangle blind
and they're just like have no idea
what's going on except they're getting
free money
and the average person in america is
also getting free money 34
of all the income is transfer payments
from the government they too have no
idea
what's value and what's valueless they
have no idea what they're eating for
example that's how you see
the obesity problem in america they
think high fructose corn syrup is the
same thing
as actual food so they go
up 500 pounds then they get sick and
they wonder how did that happen
because you become moronic due to free
money printing so as i said
no one expects a spanish inquisition no
one expects plucky's advice to actually
be taken
and it was taken so we had
manufacturers doing the thing that any
manufacturer would
ordinarily do if you're about to face a
crisis right like a pandemic you pull
your orders you're not going to need
there's going to be no demand obviously
well they were wrong
the other thing that they supply the
pandemic did expose however and i think
that's a lot of bluster that you're
seeing and all this money being thrown
is that they you know our politicians
essentially wanted to be blameless
because they told us that there would be
no cost
to exporting basically our entire
manufacturing base
and yet it exposed that there was a huge
cost
we couldn't get masks and of course now
we have the semiconductor chip
shortage the article here in wall street
points out that u.s semiconductor
manufacturing
has declined to where it is only 12
of the world's total now and this is
what
intel's new ceo pat gelsinger said in an
interview recently just this past week
on cbs is 60 minutes he said quote and
anybody who looks at supply chains says
that's a problem it's a problem he said
because relying on one region
especially one as unpredictable as asia
where 75
of the chips are made is highly risky so
here's a guy going on cbs to
basically pitch to the american public
give me 50 billion dollars
and you know those asians can't be
trusted like
even though i benefited from it by
billions our company benefited
by billions and they for example did
share buybacks of 84.5 billion dollars
in the past 10 years
so 84.5 billion dollars handed to the
insiders essentially
they didn't have to invest in capex they
didn't have to invest in supply chains
in america
because of asia so they benefited from
now and now they're going to the
audience with a
slight xenophobia saying hey you don't
want the asians to get head give me 50
billion dollars
you know give me give me give me give me
give me more give me more everybody's
where
where's my money he's this is the ce
level
ceo level of where's my money yeah this
is very a remarkable
development in the last 18 months really
it's quite sudden so for
10 or 20 years certainly since the
clinton years when
china was led into the world trade
organization the idea was that
china is an up and coming country we
need to help them out give them a hand
it's a great uh people oh you know
chinese people
and uh we're gonna send them all of our
jobs and they'll always take our money
and there'll never be any problems and
then suddenly within 18 months people
are saying wait a minute
uh in fact here's what we're going to
say we're going to say
in order to get more money out of the
taxpayer
we're going to start the xenophobic
thing going on we're going to start
attacking chinese people as
untrustworthy as a way to get more free
money
and um there's no end to it it's um
the the lies the deception the racism
the xenophobia
the class war that will never end as
long as
there's free money available yeah right
there's nothing that will stop
stop you you will say anything and do
anything to get that free money
so you and i started doing content in
this sort of space in the early 2000s
and
the this next bit here is so remarkable
you're not going to believe it about
what he said so
this is the the incentives of this fiat
structure
and how it harms the entirety of the
global economy
but also domestically so here's
something he said
about the mistakes they've made in the
past so they have a choice to invest in
catbacks
to invest in production or to give
themselves some money
uh hollow out the company right he said
in this interview on 60 minutes in cbs
the company stumbled we had some product
stumbles
some manufacturing and process stumbles
perhaps the biggest
stumble was in the early 2000s when
steve jobs of
apple needed chips for a new idea the
iphone
intel wasn't interested and apple went
to asia
eventually finding tsmc the taiwan
semiconductor manufacturing company
today
is the world's most advanced chip
manufacturer producing chips that are 30
percent faster
and more powerful than intel's he said
that's exactly what we've said
since the very beginning of our content
that we've been creating
when we spoke to the likes of michael
hudson or paul craig roberts from both
sides of the aisle in terms of
uh you know right and left and what they
said is
it's in the manufacturing process
whereby
innovation happens so we chose this
company intel
chose not to innovate that's too hard
that we see that across the economy now
as everybody's following plucky's advice
is like
everybody's staying home nobody wants to
work and by not working
you're not innovating and you're not
having to confront problems
and then overcome the problems and find
solutions so
it all got exported to tsmc because they
were too lazy
to get out of bed they were like
supermodels we're too lazy to get out of
bed we get to
just financialize our company hollow out
the company and it's easy and free and
and why should i work
yeah well let's be clear the money that
they're now being sent is a bailout
yes yes for those bad mistakes right so
they made a mistake
yeah and they're getting bailed out you
see
um and with capitalism it's
the situation where if you make a
mistake you get penalized
yes right it's it would be like having
catholicism without
hell right well that's what like
speaking of no one expects the spanish
inquisition no one expects anybody to
actually
listen to dumb ideas like from plucky
right so intel
is like one of those youtube videos of
a young uh person crying
because somebody's picking on
uh madonna or uh taylor
taylor swift or somebody like this right
they're crying
so here's intel a mature company
throwing a fit
like we're stupid we're the stupidest uh
chip manufacturer in the world
we made stupid mistakes and we buy back
our own stock
please give us a bail out again so i'm
supposed to go into my pocket
right i'm going into my pocket yeah to
help these
uh idiots at intel because they're
stupid
because nobody expects anybody to follow
plucky's advice and that is against the
advice of capitalism which
is that nobody expected like adam smith
said
the invisible hand you would protect
yourself you wouldn't hollow out your
company and destroy your economy
like no one ever in all economists ever
expected that none
before plucky ever expected that people
would willingly do this
well there you have it uh one thing we
gotta take a break
and when we yeah i might mention it was
britney spears that people cried over
yeah it was britney spears
intel
we'd take a break don't go away
back to the kaiser report i'm max kaiser
time now to turn to
john titus he's a filmmaker he made the
film bailout he's also
a retired patent attorney and financial
analyst john welcome back thanks max
good to see you again
oh all right john so you filed a freedom
of information request
with the federal reserve bank what
information are you seeking from them
why are you seeking it and what has been
the response
i am after a a memo that was drafted in
by the staff and it simply referred to
in transcript as the staff there was a
2009 meeting in june
during which time the federal reserve
the fomc
was discussing how do we reduce the
balance sheet because now we've
undertaken
the expansion of balance sheet we've
started quantitative easing we started
buying these assets
and expanding the balance sheet fomc
members in the june
2009 meeting are looking down the road
talking about
how do we you know it's easy to expand
the balance sheet because we can print
money out of nothing
how do we contract the balance sheet
then one of the ways that was discussed
was using federal reserve bills not
federal reserve notes not treasury bills
fed bills
then one of the participants in the
meeting jeffrey lacker who was the
president
of the richmond fed at that time said i
was stunned
to learn in staff memos that if this
being the federal reserve bills had the
full faith and credit of the u.s
government behind it
our books would be consolidated with the
government and so what i am after
my foia request is those staff memos
the reason i'm after it is that first of
all i'm interested just as a
an american you know what you know what
would cause
the federal reserve's books to be
consolidated with the u.s government
because that would
open the fed to a massive dose of
transparency but
really i suspect that whatever it is
that would cause the fed bills
being backed by full faith and credit to
con have those books consolidated i
suspect that the same thing
would also apply to central bank digital
currencies but i don't know that
i'm awaiting on the request the fed has
just gotten back to me recently with the
notice saying
hey we're going to give you a full
response either we will produce the
documents
we will cite an exemption to the foia by
may 14th that's a friday
it sounds like another issue here is
that
it would be a violation of this idea
that the fed is independent
right so janet yellen was at the fed now
she's at treasury
and now she gives press conferences
talking about the fed
and a lot of people say that well in
order to solve this crisis there
needs to be a consolidation of the
treasury and the fed
so what you're looking at here if in
fact they consolidate fed bills
that would mean that we no longer have
any pretense
of an independent fed john you have to
remember
that the federal reserve is a creature
of congress and answers to congress the
fed likes to style
independence as independents of both the
executive branch
and of congress which is nonsense it is
an independent agency in independent
agencies in the federal government that
means independent
of the executive branch the president
can't come in and
hire and fire you know heads of agencies
it does not mean that the fed
is independent of congress it is a
creature of congress
the congress can reach in and get
created the fed it can
close the fed down whenever it wants the
issue of consolidation
is really an issue of transparency
because the issuing members the
the parties and the entities that are
issuing the currency
in the u.s in the federal reserve are
all private
there are 12 regional federal reserve
banks in the system
each of which is private and so that's
the real issue it's really a
transparency issue
with the consolidation is you know we
want to look at those memos and see what
is it
that we can cause the consolidation of
the books now i suspect that the
consolidation
relates to the fact that the fed is
stepped into the shoes of the treasury
and it is issuing
really issuing forms of money with those
federal reserve bills
that it doesn't have the authorization
to do but i don't know i have to wait to
see those memos
if they ever show up they can call
anything they want money they can call
repurchase agreements money
right so repurchase agreements now are
considered money
and they print them up by the banks and
by the trillions
along with every other phony baloney
that they call money
the result of course is that the balance
sheet of the fed increases by trillions
and what is the current status i mean uh
the fed reserve balance sheet when it
went over a trillion
that was considered alarming we're well
past that now what what's the current
situation the fed balance sheet back in
2008 when the crisis hit
as you say was below a trillion dollars
and it went over 1 trillion
in the crisis and it rocketed up to
about 4 and a half trillion 5 trillion
and stayed there now it's about it's
pushing 8 trillion
it's 7.8 or 7.9 trillion the last we
looked
and that is you know the fed issues you
know that that's predominantly
that money is federal reserve notes
which is sitting at two point
you know some odd trillion two point one
two point two trillion dollars
and a lot of its reserves which is
electronic money that sits in the
reserve accounts of the banks
that are to subscribe to the fed and so
that balance sheet is massive
and it's all so it's their so-called
liabilities
um that are balanced out by the assets
that those that those
reserves are purchasing you know mostly
u.s treasuries but also a lot of
mortgage-backed securities right it's
mostly uh junk that they buy from wall
street
that has no resale value so net net of
the potential resale value with the junk
that they're swapping with wall street
the fed is leveraged probably close to
70 to 1.
so that's a very unstable situation
similar to other central banks around
the world and they can't raise interest
rates because that would mean
that what they do have on the books
would become instantaneously insolvent
and here we are entering into an
inflationary period where the classic
response by
the treasury and the fed would be to
raise rates
to try to stem the inflation but of
course they can't do that
so are we just heading into a crack up
boom or uh the
fed is impotent to do anything because
they've already
blown their uh box of tools
out of the water by uh the actions that
they've taken
and and uh this crack up boom is
one that will go on without a response
right it's out of control it's a rogue
right well we don't know i mean it looks
that way right now
as you say you cannot raise the interest
rates the juice on the debt
just the interest payment on the debt is
massive if you just raise the interest
rate a little bit
the debt goes up the interest payment on
the debt goes up so much
to where you risk not being able to make
the interest payment on the debt
jerome powell himself recently said they
were on an unsustainable track meaning
you have debt growing at a pace that is
greater than gdp and he said
he admitted that's unsustainable now he
claims that the 28 trillion dollars in
debt
itself that's sustainable by itself you
know i don't know whether that's true or
not
but he's exactly correct that the growth
rate of the
of the fed the debt is outpacing the gdp
and that's the real danger the fed
itself admits
that it's really kind of an out it's on
an out of control trajectory
right now and there's no indication that
anybody's applying the brakes
they'll say that um oh gosh we care
about people so much we're gonna
introduce universal basic income or a
modern monetary theory mmt
which is just more money printing right
so they're going to rebrand it one thing
i've noticed about wall street over the
decades
that i've been involved is that they
commit the same frauds every five
to ten years but they rebranded right so
um this one this mmt or ubi
will be the latest bailout of wall
street
because of course all the payouts will
be distributed through wall street
and they'll take their cut but it's
essentially just another bailout for
wall street
we know very little about cbdc just
except what
the what officials tell us like jay
powell and they say it's the third
liability the balance sheet
you know meaning that you would be you
know right now the only people with
account the only entities with accounts
at the federal reserve or the treasury
and foreign central banks
and american commercial banks you know
in some formats with with american
presence and that's really it
what they're contemplating with central
bank digital currencies
is allowing ordinary americans and
ordinary businesses
to have accounts at the fed electronic
accounts at the fed
so they're saying it would be the third
form of money the first two being
cash physical cash and the second one
being reserves
and they're saying the third would be
central bank digital currency
but it would be individual accounts and
really i look at that not so much
as the third liability i don't think
it's a liability at all it's really to
me
the system is out of control as you said
and it's been out of control we started
to see
you know cracks in the in the edifice in
september of 2019 that predated the
pandemic
incidentally and with the repo market
the new york fed and so i think the
system is starting to shake
out of control and the cbdc in that
system
i think is really a reach to try to rein
in control
and have a you know one unitary monetary
system
where you know there's a lot more
control mechanisms built in
and hence you see all these things like
oh we need to be concerned about green
energy
and we need to be concerned about
inclusion and all these other nice
subjects that's all just a pretense for
the fed to be able to exercise
control in my opinion we don't know time
will tell
as we learn more and more about cbdc
from the fed officials
right the central bank digital
currencies appear to be a way for
the powers that be to do an end run
around the wall street banks actually
and um so that'll be an interesting
conflict between those two groups now
you made the documentary bailout during
the
global financial crisis today we're in
the midst of a looks like a
global crack up boom uh from all this
inflation or money printing
the bailouts are are are permanent and
eternal
um it seems like it's just rolling
bailouts one on top of the other
but is this now a up boom uh
it's different than 2008 john because in
you had the bubble pop and they came in
with
what eventually became almost 20
trillion dollars worth of funny money
and uh but now they've caused
a weimar germany zimbabwe like
hyperinflationary cycle uh
your thoughts it is different from 2008
but you're right let's back up bailouts
are forever once you once you take that
step
and you start bailing people out there's
to me to my way of thinking it's a
ratchet rents there's no going back
the other thing there's no going back on
is that we've dispensed with the rule of
law
you know we've known about that ever
since 2013 when doj officials
announced very candidly that they were
no longer really they admitted
they were no longer prosecuting wall
street banks and that's another thing
you can't really reverse that because
once you give somebody criminal immunity
you know they're just gonna run with it
and then at that point there's no voting
your way out of that system
so you're right the system is out of
control it is criminally out of control
and now i think what you're seeing in
terms of the difference between now and
is 2008 you could just lavish a lot of
cash on a bunch of banks and it sort of
you know stem the bleeding and now what
you're seeing
is the the federal reserve which is
really the ultimate
it's it's one notch up the monetary
chain from the banks
you know the banks issue bank money the
federal reserve issues reserves
and now what we're seeing is indications
that the fed is going to start using
those reserves
or using its issuing power to connect
with ordinary people
and as you said they're really
short-circuiting out the banks with that
and that's really a radical departure
from 2008 when the banks were
sort of part of the solution now the fed
is stepping up and cutting the banks out
john we're going to have to cut it off
there i'll be back on soon to talk about
this stuff thanks for being on kaiser
report
thanks max all right and that's going to
do it for this edition of kaiser report
with me max kaiser and stacy herbert
want to thank our guest john
titus until next time bye y'all
[Music]